نحن الان في شارع الستين وهذا احد الباصات
الذي هو في طريقه الى مدينه بورسودان هناك
عدد من العائلات دخلت الى هذا الباص تريد
الخروج من العاصمه الخرطوم وهناك عدد اخر
من الجاليات المختلفه هناك اتراك وهناك
مصريه في هذا الباص نحاول
الذهاب اليهم ومعرفه احوالهم وكيف خرجوا
من مناطقكم التي كانوا فيها
نسقته مع بعض ولا الامور تجيده بس الشارع
الصباح ولقينا العربات يعني في في مجموعه
من الناس الباصات لكن نحن عشان ساكنين
قريب فقلنا اصلا
ونشوف الحاصل فجينا قبل ثلاثه ساعات
والحمد لله توثقنا هم خطر لحد البيوت عشان
المشاكل كان زمان بنمشي يمين البري حسي
يمين البري اصعب والشارع ما مضمون الا
بنطلع الصباح بالليل بتكون الاوضاع ما
كويسه بيكون في ضرب رصاص وفي ذخيره
[موسيقى]
من خلال قناه الجزيره احب اطمن اهلي
واخواتي في السعوديه وابويا وامي انه انا
بخير ان شاء الله وان شاء الله قريب قريب
ان شاء الله ربي يجمعنا فيك يا رب اهلي
كلهم على خير ان شاء الله
هناك تخوفات كبيره من هؤلاء الناس على ان
الاوضاع قد تزداد سوءا وقد تصل الى مراحل
اكبر في ظل نقص في الخدمات خدمات العلاجيه
وان الاحتياجات الاساسيه بالنسبه
للمواطنين من ماء وشراب وخبز فلذلك هذه
الاشياء كلها دفعت المواطنين والمقيمين في
الخرطوم الى الخروج منها بحثا عن ملاذ امن
او الخروج من خارج البلاد كليه
هذا بالنسبه لاولئك الناس الذين لديهم
اموال يستطيعون التحرك بها عبر هذه
الباصات هناك اخرين ليست لديهم من المال
الكافي للخروج من هذه المنطقه
بخمسين
وطبعا بنكك ما في كاش ما شغال يعني انا
بستغرب ليه الناس في استغلاليه للدرجه دي
المفروض الناس تجيف مع بعض وتساعد بعض
عشان الناس تطلع من الحته اللي هي فيها دي
الوضع يبدو انه
هناك خوف من السكان القطوم بانه بعد عمليه
جلاء الرعايه
الاجانب والمقيمين في هذه المنطقه قد
تتحول الخرطوم الى الساحه للحرب مره اخرى
ويكون معترفها ساخنا فلذلك هناك تحرك كبير
من المواطنين الى الخروج لكن هناك اخرين
ليس لديهم اموال تمكنهم من الخروج من
الخرطوم محمد الطيب الجزيره جنوب الخطوط